like when i started doing jiu jitsu
and all of a sudden people are just hey
when you see someone it's like a hug
that was new to me yeah and now i think
it's more commonplace
would you call yourself a hugger now i
think that's probably a strong word
because if i don't legit know you and we
don't train or whatever
probably you're not you're not getting a
hug from this guy
so if let's say you know a person you
know
maybe not for years but you know you're
familiar with them or whatever
do you want to hug them like are you
compelled to give them a hug i'm not
saying are you standing there looking at
him
are we talking about talking or what are
we talking
straight up whatever kind of hug the
thing to me there's a huge difference
between a
hug and a bro hug okay so the minimum
hug
you're not no i'm not i'm not hugging
anyone really i mean
i'll bro hug all kinds of people like a
handshake with like a
one arm wrap on the back boom right um
oh i asked because
i am now that i'm kind of evaluating it
i am a hugger down when i really
compelled
look i don't stand there and be like man
i'd really like to hug you right now
it's not that kind
but yeah when i'm saying what up to you
and i just
shake someone's hand or whatever i feel
like i feel like i
just wanted a little bit more to be
honest with you is that everybody you
meet
yes pretty much yeah see i guess you and
i are a little different if i like them
yes for sure
yeah yeah yeah but i think it does come
from the combination of
hawaii and jiu-jitsu yeah don't be
getting crazy trying to hug me
hug you every time i see you just face
it i mean what covet is
impacting all this stuff right now you
can't some people can't even shake hands
now
like it's a fist bump right yeah hugging
probably
percentage of hugging going way down
right now way down you're in a hurt
locker room
brutal you're just mentally distraught
what's funny is i feel that
like the no shaking hands no hugging or
whatever like i feel it when i
like see somebody like i feel like wait
like we didn't even like shake hands and
hug nothing
we're just sort of we just came to see
each other and now we're just talking
like we skipped the whole
thing it's what it feels like you know
freaking cold echo charles having some
psychological withdrawal